friends and family will soon be knocking
on your door so you have to ask yourself
what are they going to see on your
floors and carpet if the answer is dirt
and old stains it is time to call in
Zerorez the sponsors of this segment and
I'm joined by Ben McKee and Doug McKee
from Zerorez on with some tips on how
you can make your holidays cleaner
welcome back you guys thanks good to see
you Mercedes you too now tell us what is
the number one thing you would recommend
to people that are going to be hosting
guests the biggest thing I mean our
guests come I don't know about your
in-laws but my in-laws come in they're
looking at my floors or looking out
through my houses so Zerorez is here to
help and save the day so as you got
people coming in give us a call we can
get your place cleaned up and smelling
fresh and it's not just carpets but
let's talk about the carpets for a
minute because you guys have this
patented ZR technology and if people
don't know what it is it really is the
greatest way to clean your carpets tell
us a little bit about it so as you see I
understand you got we're cleaning
carpets it's a traditional hot water
extract action but what we do on
traditional is we don't use any soaps
harsh chemicals or surfactants and what
that does is it allows your carpets to
stay cleaner longer you don't have any
dirt attracting residue left behind and
that's what causes the crunchy carpets
which we all hate and it just smells
fresh when we're done because there's no
chemical deodorizers being used and I'll
throw this into your carpet stripe
faster too it's really really nice it's
incredible I mean we'll show you later
on but we clean with a basically a 300
horsepower vacuum our truck mounts
powered by the truck's engine of the van
now oh yeah we're going Doug we want to
see you work in and just some of the
zero rest technology in action it's
pretty amazing
this is my favorite part this is the one
swipe where you have this dirty carpet
and with one swipe with only water right
this is literally the power of water I
think you can see right away it's a
night and day difference and like you
think like oh I get nervous coming on TV
to see this but every time we're able to
remove the dirt the grease the grime
that's in the carpet and it's just hot
water it's our ZR water and it cleans
great and it dries really fast now we
only have a couple of seconds left but I
have to talk about this too air ducts
air ducts are so important you clean
those too we do so get your whole our
whole approach is get your home clean
from top to bottom yeah improve the
indoor air quality of your home get your
ductwork clean and we could do that at
your home and at your business so give
us a call yeah they go to businesses if
you want to make sure that your
employees are happy and not walking on
carpet that looks like that I don't know
where you got that from but that is a
good point now you guys always bring a
special to the table what have you got
going on you do so our pre-holiday
special right now you get three rooms of
carpet cleaning for only 119 Plus for
the holiday season we're gonna throw in
a free family pass to glittering lights
down at the speedway yeah that is such a
fun time you guys are giving us the gift
of clean
and the chance to experience glittering
lights thank you so much thank you to
Zerorez for sponsoring this segment call
them so they can get your home holiday
ready three rooms of carpet cleaned for
only 119 plus a three family pass to
glittering lights that drive through
light display at the Las Vegas Motor
Speedway you can call them at that
number right there
702-840-333 or go online to
zerorezlasvegas.com for more information
minimums apply
Las Vegas now we'll be right back
[Music]